d'ici une semaine et les commerces vont
rouvrir leurs portes à la clientèle
depuis quelques jours les collaborateurs
du centre de westfield vélizy 2
reviennent ils préparent les magasins à
la réouverture du 19 mai il faut les
nettoyer il faut rien planter les
nouvelles collections printemps-été par
exemple refaire venir tous les
collaborateurs les reformer pour être
prêt pour le grand jour
enfin la réouverture le 19 mai nos
prestataires partenaires sont sur le
pied de guerre aussi pour revoir
l'ensemble de la signalétique
réapprovisionner les bornes de gel
vraiment être prêt est vraiment garantir
les meilleures conditions d'accueil
sanitaire
le 19 mai le protocole sanitaire sera le
même que celui établi précédemment un
sens de circulation unique et des
messages audio un espacement d'un mètre
dans les files d'attentes ou encore un
conteur d'affluence nouveauté pour la
réouverture à venir des capteurs de co2
pour mesurer la qualité de l'air et
lorsqu'on se rapproche des seuils à ne
pas dépasser
on va enclencher les ventilations des
renouvellement de l'air naturel ou
mécanique en ouvrant les portes en
ouvrant les auvents toiture voir les
exutoires de désenfumage le centre
attend le retour des clients avec
impatience eu des clients vite revenu
lors des précédentes réouverture avec
une envie de se retrouver et de
consommer on a vu donc des taux de
transformation et des paniers moyens
vraiment en nette progression
donc plutôt des bonnes surprises aux
précédentes réouverture tout en
respectant les mesures sanitaires ici
200 magasins ouvriront leurs portes le
19 mai